the new Samson active - or the Apple
watch Series five honestly it is a tough
choice right now what's going on guys my
name is David homage and welcome back to
the channel today we're talking about
the two highly competitive SmartWatch
manufacturers in 2019 yes we are talking
about the Samsung active 2 which has
just been recently announced and the
all-time hero and favorite the Apple
watch Series 5 so if you watch the
Samsung unpacked event like many of us
did you would have found that there was
a lot of limited information on the
Samsung active to watch they didn't
really go into too much detail and they
didn't really promote it very well in my
personal opinion I think the presenter
lacked a little bit of experience or a
little bit of emotion really to sell
this product to us but when you actually
do go back and take a look at all the
features and the functions of active -
well in its entirety it's an actually a
really amazing product whereas the Apple
series 5 has been out for a little while
now so we know all the features and all
the gadgets it has which means we're
able to compare both of these models
today to help you and potentially may
make this decision in which one to
purchase in the future so the senses
active comes in two different models the
40 millimeter and the 44 millimeter
personally the 40 millimeter is probably
the ideal option for me because I do
have smaller wrists but people with
larger wrists would definitely be going
up for the 44 if I was somebody going
out to buy one of these watches I would
be trying them both on in stores before
making any online purchase so when we
take a look at the Samsung active two we
straight away know that it comes in two
different case styles the cheaper
Bluetooth only version comes in an
aluminium shell whilst the more
expensive LTE version comes in a
stainless steel case now everything that
I've seen so far people are raving about
the stainless steel case because it is
that
a bit more of a premium feel it's got a
little bit more weight to it and overall
it is better finished product but you
are paying a significantly higher margin
to purchase at Elte a model and then you
have ongoing costs for you to be
purchasing a plan for this device as
well personally speaking I don't see the
need of having an LTE enabled watch
because everywhere I go I do have my
phone with me but if you are purchasing
it to link up with your smart headphones
or wireless headphones or anything along
those lines and you don't want to take
your phone along for a run or you just
want to have the convenience of being
able to use Google Maps anywhere on the
go then the LTA function is a great
feature to have especially if you like
leaving your phone behind and not having
those instructions so there are a couple
of unique features of the active two
that I really like and I think we
persuade a lot of people to jump ship to
the active versus the Apple series 5 but
having said that there's also some
amazing features in the apple series 5
which is trying to push me towards that
series as well so reverse wireless
charging is the number one key feature
for me on the Samsung active 2 it means
if you do have a new S 10 device you can
just simply place your watch on the back
of your phone and charge both of them
overnight without having to plug into
devices the second feature in the
Samsung active 2 which is an upgrade
from the servicing active one which only
actually came out about six months ago
so it is a very bold move from Samsung
to bring out active to already is the
simple implementation of a speaker this
speaker now allows you to play music set
your alarm or even listen to YouTube
videos on your watch from the single
device alone now I don't know how many
people are there are going to be
watching YouTube on their watch on this
little tiny screen but look there
probably are a few scenarios where you
might need to pop up a quick video just
to demonstrate something or maybe you
just want to set your alarm in a meeting
or anything like that so there are
definitely some benefits in having this
inbuilt speaker into the active to a
feature that I think is super useful and
super handy for
people like myself who do go traveling
quite a bit to foreign countries and
don't speak every language Under the Sun
is simply the fact that Google Translate
is built into your watch so yes I know
you can use it on your phone but it is a
nice little feature to have when you're
connected to Wi-Fi or the LTE network
now the last feature I want to talk
about here on active too is something
that hasn't been fda-approved yet and it
is implemented in the device but it
isn't active in the device yet and that
is the ECG or the electrocardiogram
basically what this feature does is that
monitors your heart rate and notices if
there are any irregularities in the beat
in the rhythm and that way it can notify
you if you have any heart problems and
you need to go seek medical attention
now I know smartwatches are a thing of
modern beauty but if you're more into
analog watches and you do love the
classic look make sure you take a look
at the first link in the description
below
it's one of my companies called wire
watches which specializes in
architectural II designed timepieces so
if you are clicking on this video and
thinking maybe I don't really want a
smart watch I still love the analog
classic look take a look down and see if
you love anything from the website so
there are some amazing features of
active too but Apple series 5 also has
some incredible features and especially
if you're already connected to Apple
ecosystem this watch is an almost must
have any Apple lover something that
they've implemented in the series 5 and
they haven't had an any model since is
the always-on display usually you'd have
your watch and it would turn on when you
glanced at it or when you touch at it
and then go to a completely black screen
when you're finished however now with
the series 5 you can simply tap the
cover and it will dim the brightness
change the screen and reduce it to 1
Hertz per second refresh rate which
allows a watch to conserve battery
whilst also giving you a 24/7 always on
display now just like the active two
they have come out in two different case
materials the Bluetooth version
loan comes in the ceramic case which is
a light premium quality finish whilst
the LTA model comes with a titanium
chassis now again very similar to the
active to the titanium is a lot more
durable a lot heavier and gives you that
premium feel
which obviously paying for in the price
tag something I really dislike about the
Apple watch is how the menu is actually
coordinated and integrated it kind of
all jumbles around and throws itself
around and it seems very disorganized
the new compass addition to the Apple
watch series 5 isn't that groundbreaking
and probably won't get used by a lot of
people but the implementation of the
compass actually allows you to
understand where you're going on Google
Maps so very similar to Google Maps or
Apple Maps when you open it up on your
smartphone and you see that blue cone of
vision that indicates which direction
you're facing the SmartWatch now also
give you this preview this is super
helpful if you're traveling around and
using Apple maps on your smartphone that
you can find your way around a lot
easier you don't have to guess and judge
walk up 500 meters ago Oh walk the wrong
way have to turn around and start all
over again
so the implementation of the compass app
probably not something everybody's going
to use but the integration with Apple
maps and that kind of vision is
definitely something that is well worth
upgrading now something Apple has
focused on here and something that I
think is actually a very critical piece
of tech in any SmartWatch and something
that would almost convinced me to
purchase an Apple watch over a Samsung
watch is the anytime emergency
international calling so if you're in an
emergency situation you can easily
activate this international emergency
calling and it will automatically call
the local emergency center without
having any LTE plan activated in an
emergency setting this feature could
literally be the difference between life
or death
so what watch should you buy at the end
of the day well in my personal opinion
it really comes down to what smartphone
you have because these watches are
designed
integrate with their parent phone so if
you already own a host of Samsung
devices I would definitely recommend the
active two whereas if you already own a
host of Apple devices I would definitely
definitely recommend the Apple series 5
that's all from me guys thank you so
much for watching if you like the video
make sure you smash that subscribe
button
20-19 style and as always I'll see you
next Monday